Library.
The library is a place where there are many books.
If you become a member, you can borrow any books you want.
Library.
School.
Teachers work in the school.
They teach lots of things to young children.
School.
Store.
Stores sell many things.
There are different types of stores like the grocery store...
...where we buy fruit or the shoe store where we buy shoes.
Store.
Museum.
The museum is a place...
...where you can see artwork like paintings...
...and old objects like sculptures.
Museum.
Hotel.
The hotel is where people stay for a short while.
Normally, hotels provide lodging for people...
...who don't live in the city or are on vacation.
Hotel.
Cafe.
At the cafe, you can have coffee and other drinks.
The waiter will serve them to you.
Cafe.